alors oui alors grâce à moi je te
cultive oui je sais ce que c'est qu'une
pièce de molière maintenant ah ouais
c'est vraiment bien je suis content que
tu vas prennent tous ah oui et puis j'ai
pas mais j'aimerais bien rencontrer
l'auteur qu'elle révèle comme s'il avait
le temps de te recevoir alors tu as aimé
tu as aimé j'ai jamais rien vu d'aussi
chiant même les comédiens son plateau
ils sont endormis au mieux tu rigoles
n'en attends tu peux voir les petites de
la pièce là qu'on vient de voir la belle
au bois dormant pourquoi pauvres mais
fabien cette pièce va bien je n'ai pas
très bien compris le dénouement mais
chérie c'est pas fini c'est l'entracte
ah bon il nous manquait c'était fort un
jour tu vas y tu vas shakespeare c'est
un gars qui est qui dans son répertoire
est le seul avec othello avoir pensé à
donner des rôles au rouge
au comédien hubert spectacle a très bien
géré la durée pour le guitariste a cassé
ses guitares sur son genou et a brandi
son sexe vers le public après tout moi
moi j'ai été conquis 1 et je ne veux
voir karajan maintenant dorénavant
qu'avec un blouson cuir une banane
c'était bien mais coûte la prochaine
fois on ira l'hôtel sont si chers on est
allongé au moins cher qu'à écouter
s'était pas vu le vraiment fabuleux ya
bien roulé dans cette pièce vous voulez
ya une espèce de de gestuelle de
recherche de l'espace c'est fabuleux si
c'est vrai c'est toi et moi j'y vois une
espèce d'objective isation n'est ce pas
de la scène pas réellement à ceux de
l'acteur qui revient à confier attendu
ce mois sur le ca a oui tout à fait mais
il arrive à un point de maturité
étonnant et autant repoussé si vous
voulez on va te féliciter je connais
jean jacques debout ah ben je connais
parfaitement chantal goya le dire
franchement cette pièce là j'ai rien
compris rien rien du tout quoi t'as rien
compris la pièce va bien et sont bien
devoir gérer un groupe kuta bruit
quelques chanceux c'est vide en moi ça
me parle moi moi aussi j'y comprends
rien j'ai tout compris moi c'est ici
c'est limpide
tu as compris un truc à sa toile et oui
c'est clair comme de l'eau normale à son
nom soit sympa explique moi et tout
puisque j'ai rendez vous
tu m'as bien sûr du théâtre à bord qui
se tarit voir je vais voir une pièce un
homme un homme nommé un homme nommé un
homme nommé hossein
quand tu veux dire je les ai pensé la
même chose voire homard gueuse vraiment
je suis déçu moi j'adore les spectacles
de danse et ça vraiment je suis déçue
déçue déçue
on a eu de belles filles 1 non mais tu
comprends ça sélectivement d'originalité
tu vois les décors est nu je vais te
dire la musique et d'asséner fiant je
dirais danseurs on se demande où ils ont
appris à danser
tu vas me dire moi j'ai été profondément
déçu surtout la danse est profond je
suis désormais de belles cuisses
bon on va thiviers à les ir mais bon
dieu tu le savais et évite les
strapontins c'était déjà arrivé
ajoutez super hein mais j'ai pas
vraiment repris le tapis rouge l'art du
tapis rouge c'est le sang du peuple
on sent que ce pape après l'effort
d'accord edit et les feuilles qui
tombent elles et tu n'as pas compris non
mais c'est la décadence de la
bourgeoisie ça c'est laid c'est la
bourgeoisie qui tombe dans le fond la
sonnerie de dupont la faucille et le
marteau ça j'ai pas compris dans sa
boîte et la voile alors dit moi là il
était comment les les décors comment non
d'aider les décors il était comment un
nom il faut résister
ce concert va pouvoir faire l'amour
plutôt bien on voit que c'est parti
ça bizarre non ça c'est déjà assez
bizarre aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu as
pensé de ces trois heures de musique
indienne
bah c'est pas fini sont pas encore
commencé la danse est terminée la rame
en panne
je crois qu'ils accordaient leurs
instruments halimi s'était bien passé
j'étais alors qu est-ce qu on était dans
la fosse à la faute
et toi tu étais bien placé dans les
baignoires oui
ito par terre dans les cintres
vous avez la chance les gars moi j'étais
au poulailler